my career is one of the most play
features in NBA 2k franchise history to
take it to the next level we are
introducing face scan technology for the
first time your time has come to put
yourself in the game like never before I
want to show you how it works to face
scan yourself an NBA 2k15 you need to
hold the PlayStation Eye camera six to
12 inches away from your face the
scanning process will begin and you will
need to slowly turn your head 30 degrees
to the left and 30 degrees to the right
this process is quick and simple only
taking about 30 seconds to complete this
technology doesn't just match what looks
like you but maps your entire face into
small points and creates your features
and look it's not capturing an image
it's capturing the 3d model of your
entire face which brings more realism
than any system before from there you
can sculpt your head how you want from
the front or profile view with our
extremely deep customization options and
bam virtual Ronnie TK is in the game now
wait until you see yourself talking to
NBA players earning prestige in your
career and one day leading your team to
the promised land your time has come
only in NBA 2k15
[Music]